Like the others, Skinner thought that we evolved such that we have the vocal
apparatus to be able to learn language. And in fact Skinner though that we
learn language just like we learn any other behavior. And that's why he calls
it verbal behavior. We are surrounded by verbal communities and they teach us
the sounds and words that are effective in that community. And you'll notice
that parents use imitation and reinforcement when teaching their children how
to talk. That's right Johnny, you said water, good job. So in addition to
reinforcement, you may also be punished for language. For example, perhaps you
said a curse word in front of somebody you shouldn't have and you got in
trouble for it. If you speak differently to your friends than you do to your
parents or your grandparents, you would have what Skinner would say, audience
control. Meaning you're reinforced to speak in a certain way in front of some
people, and speaking that way in front of others, you could actually be
punished. If language were discovered, then why didn't Jeannie learned how to
speak. Well actually, we saw that Jeannie did try to speak, and was imitating,
but she was punished for it, remember, her dad barked at her. Therefore she had
limited language skills. Finally we're going to ask again why is it very
important and we hope that we can get some practical applications from a
theory. And it turns out theory of Skinner in verbal behavior using principles
of operand conditioning has been very effective in teaching children with
autism how to speak. And they even use these theories to teach individuals with
intellectual disabilities how to speak.